they call themselves Anonymous they are
hackers on steroids like an Internet
Hate Machine their name comes from their
secret websites for Jam the infamous
Anonymous image board otherwise known as
the bottomless world of degeneracy means
unfiltered discussions and [ __ ] posting
a lot a lot of [ __ ] posting given this
often unfavorable reputation it can be
hard to imagine associating any word
synonymous with good or wholesome to
come from such a place but every so
often there comes a story of some
incredible Collective Feats originating
from there and even more unusually it
can sometimes serve as a platform for
people to come together to create
something extraordinary this is one of
those times a story that started with a
single image from of all places a hentai
dojinshi what follows would be a series
of chaotic and improbable events
spanning years that would lead to one of
the most incredible projects to see the
light of day because not only were a
group of strangers able to band together
to complete a monumentally large project
that would take years to produce but
even more improbable is that it resulted
in one of the greatest visual novels to
ever come out of the western anime
Community this is the story of the time
4chan made an a rogue that blew
everyone's expectations away this is the
story of katawa Shojo
[Music]
but before we get on that I wanted to
talk about today's sponsor boxu is my
favorite Japanese snack box that sources
rare snacks from all over Japan
partnering with family businesses to
create signature trees you can't find
anywhere else now if you've been living
in Japan like me one of my favorite
things about Japan is of course their
food culture which absolutely applies to
the awesome snacks that they have and if
you've ever wanted to try any of them
box who's got you covered each box is
completely packed with Japanese snacks
and also comes with a little booklet
that teaches you all about the snacks
unique flavors and where they come from
this month if you're in America you may
be preparing for Halloween but in Japan
we have Autumn Koyo which is the
beautiful season where we get to see all
the leaves changed to the beautiful fall
colors and all the snacks I have here
perfectly match the mood of the theme
we're going for here I'm gonna try this
Yuzu cake for myself now I'm very
excited for this because I am a fiend
for Yuzu I love Yuzu flavor things
oh that sounds so refreshing God I love
you Zoo oh
we also have Mochi oranges now unlike
another certain someone I absolutely
love oranges and orange flavored stuff
so let's give this a shot
that's cute they're almost shaped like
orange segments
give me both of them how can you hate
oranges so what are you waiting for if
you want to try out some premium
Japanese snacks today go to the link in
the description and use code gigock15
for 15 off your first boxu order thank
you very much to boxy for sponsoring me
today back to the video before the Gold
Rush of steam anime themed visual novels
before Doki Doki literature club before
Honey Pop there was katawa Shoujo
released in 2012 katawa Shojo which
roughly translates into disability girls
is a visual novel dating Sim that tells
the story of five high school girls
living with various disabilities who you
get to romance and who knows maybe
eventually get a bit of sexy time with
yeah I know given the very sensitive
subject matter and given the place it
originated from it's easy to expect
nothing less than a tasteless disaster
that would go down in infamy in the
bowels of the internet and yet anyone
who's played this will know that it was
a wholesome inspirational story that has
touched the hearts of many and is still
very very loved to this day even now
I've seen countless people talk about
how katawa Shojo touched their lives and
sometimes even changed it in some way
one thing that I find just as incredible
as the story of the game itself is the
story of how this project got made this
isn't some small game it is a full
visual novel with 30 plus hours of
content complete with CGS music and
animation that took a team of amateur
developers years to make and was
released for absolutely free this was
before the era of the steam visual novel
boom before Kickstarter projects before
easily accessible visual novels in
general just a group of strangers
working without pay for years on a
project that might never had been
finished the more I think about this
project the more it blows my mind that
Not only was something like this scene
to completion but also turned out as
incredible as it was how did such a
project get completed where so many
other smaller games Indie titles and
kickstarters with proper funding
faltered forgotten about never to see
the light of day to see the roots of
where this all started we need to go
back much earlier to a simpler time of
the internet
[Music]
enjoy life visual novels and Interactive
driven video game that are more often
than not displayed with an anime-esque
art style in fact visual novels
originated from Japan itself and still
arguably makes up a large percentage of
the PC games that are released from
there some visual novels also double as
a dating Sim where at least one of the
main goals involves the player trying to
romance one or multiple characters
through the interactive narrative or as
I like to call it a touch grass
simulator as the player it's your job to
make choices that affect the overarching
story and the relationships you forge
with other characters while every choice
you make potentially branches off into a
different storyline with multiple
endings some Vision novels are pure
romances some are fantasy or science
fiction stories and some of them were
porn like a lot of them
a lot of them were
and still are
some big games that are basically visual
novels are franchises like Phoenix
Wright and the danganron Romper series
but some others you may have heard of
are things like steinsgate clanard and
what does this say
Fate Stay Night
never heard of it however back in the
day it was really hard to get a hold of
any of these copies unless you actually
lived in Japan there was no visual
novels on Steam not on Marketplace there
was hardly even any official
translations so a lot of the weaves
during those early days of the instead
took it upon themselves to try and
spread the love through fan translations
of pre-existing Japanese visual novels I
know this is gonna sound absolutely
alien to anyone below the age of like
[ __ ] 25 or something but getting
visual novels back then was a Navy Seals
level operation of difficulty you had to
go in some dodgy website and Download 50
separate dot raw files individually on
the slowest internet that you can only
do one at a time which would only allow
you to download like five files per day
so you're kind of just praying to God
that you're not just downloading these
files for multiple days I need to get to
file 49 and find the link is broken and
you're gonna have to find some other
website and start all over again
sorry I'm getting some Vietnam
flashbacks right now but through this a
whole culture of parody visual novels
were formed because any old we could
still ask flash Game dating
so there must have been a few of you out
there that discovered that shitty Ava
dating Sim and the love in a visual
novel back in the day browsing new
grounds and seeing stuff like ganguro
girl Frank's adventure and just having
your World opened as a horny hormonal
teenage anime fan if you do please make
yourself known so I don't sound like a
crazy Boomer right now thinking back to
the fan made bootleg dating Sims of the
mid-2000s feels like a [ __ ] fever
dream but all this was the landscape of
the community at the time because let's
be real we were [ __ ] weaves and a lot
of us had that same cringy dream of
wanting to make our own anime one day
and visual novels were kind of the
closest we could ever get to that with
the resources we had so while I can't
exactly explain why the collective of
4chan's anime board would jump on the
idea of creating a visual novel it's
very possible that this would have sown
the seeds of interest for many on that
board to want to make their own though
for the origin of the disabled girl
dating Sim idea itself we need to go
back even further sometimes an idea can
Sprout out at any time in a place you
wouldn't expect and fukata or Shojo that
would come in the form of a bloody
Miyazaki film
Nazca Valley of the wind is a classic
anime film that's been credited for
being the origin of Studio Ghibli itself
but we're not here to talk about the
1984 Miyazaki classic or even its
original manga we're here to talk about
his hentai
nice in December of the year 2000 the
dojin circles that I Shojo released a
Nazca of the Valley of the Wind dojin
Called
schupen Harnish really hope I pronounced
that one correctly the dojan would
center around the character kushana who
in the world of NASCAR is a princess
who's had two of her legs and one of her
arms amputated cause everyone loves that
amputee tag right guys hey yo what the
[ __ ] the main body of the dojin itself
isn't too important as it's just a
standard dojin doing dojin things nice
nice nice nice but what's really
important here is that the artist who
went by writer would include some extra
omic pages
Japanese [ __ ] do you speak and
on one particular page there would
include concept art for a dating Sim
featuring disabled girls that he dubbed
katawa Shoujo there was a deaf girl he
was a class president type an armless
girl who would hold up her chopsticks
with her feet one had no legs one had
severe burn scars and the last one was
blind it was all just very basic ideas
with not much to work with and I'm sure
a writer himself had no idea how
important this single page Would One Day
become the real event that would set
this idea in motion however would come a
whole six years later where for some
unknown reason a fan would choose to
color and translate this page and this
page alone and knowingly putting the
final piece in place for this idea to
take center stage on a board full of
eager degenerate weaves it was the one
page from a Hentai Manga that started an
avalanche
on the 4th of January 2007 writers
translated omic page Dirty Bastard
you've done it was posted onto 4chan's
anime boards and they went crazy
hundreds of individual ideas sketches
and Concepts were thrown out there and
discussed what this dating scene would
actually be like if it were real threads
after thread after thread was created
and filled before another one would pop
up almost immediately to repeat the
exact same cycle I nominate Burns Chan
for Resident sundare are you stupid burn
face Town isn't tundering she's shy
reclusive and so Moe I'm gonna die if I
was deaf I would run around screaming
like a dying giraffe that would be fun
you guys have created the game he can
relate to congratulations enjoy your new
status it got so popular that a mod
actually had to pin one of the threads
which for a site that is all about the
impermanence and volatility of its
discussions was an extremely rare event
the unified creative Force couldn't be
stopped it had taken a mind of its own
eventually cause one were made to make
this game a reality and riding on
nothing but the sheer momentum of a
single concept page the collective hive
mind of a decided to actually do it a
development Forum was created in an
attempt to be able to collect and
organize enough ideas to give this
project a sense of coherency but the
floodgates were already opened this
unabashed Collective ushered in a no
holds Bar barefisted Royal Rumble cage
matchup ideas that battled it out on the
open Forum some took shape and evolved
and some were shot down almost as
quickly as they were born plot paths
locations character quirks character
backstories music and Folly everything
was discussed everything was open game
whether suggestions were actually
serious or not do you think she looks
more
[Music]
the platform soon became a very
different kind of Cesspool one of raw
creativity and disorganized ideas yet
somehow through all this madness the
girls were able to gain assemblance of
personality and even get names Rin Lily
she's in a Hanukkah and Emmy complete
with their kanji spelling however due to
this being decided by the collective
energy of weibus alone with little
understanding of the actual Japanese
language there were some names like
iwanko that slipped through the cracks
which isn't actually a Japanese Name the
setting would unsurprisingly be some
kind of Japanese high school that
specializes on disabled students and
unbeknownst to the fan that originally
colored the page they would have already
had one of the biggest influence in the
visual designs as the color schemes for
the school uniforms and the girls would
remain the same until the game's release
eventually though as expected the hype
would start to die and the momentum
would slow the fickle interests of
anonymous users would quickly evaporate
as they would soon go back to doing
exactly what they were doing before
leaving the few remaining stragglers to
pick up the pieces that resulted from
this chaotic stream of events as they
tried to figure out so
where the hell do we go from here
it's April 2007. four months since the
original thread post any momentum that
it originally had had almost completely
gone there's infighting about whether it
still should be an open project that the
community can always contribute to or a
closed project worked on by a dedicated
team whatever the case any progress has
almost come to a screeching halt and the
project is in real danger of dying a
slow slow death in Comes A Man by the
name of Cameron O'Neill who went by crud
online and who I was lucky enough to
interview for this video project he had
experience organizing online projects
from working as a fan server on shows
like higarashi and was basically put in
charge of organizing a new development
Forum from scratch with the handful of
remaining devs who were still interested
in pursuing the project the new ragtag
team was formed crud was in charge of
writing hanukkah's story a22 was in
charge of writing shizanese Aura for Rin
another writer for Lily's story and Hive
Minds agreed to ride to Emmy's path the
team also had people working on
character and background art as well as
an overall director who would start to
learn how to use renpi a fairly
well-known visual novel engine everyone
in this core team was given their job
and dedicated roles for the project thus
cementing the birth of four leaf studios
in reference to the 4chan logo that all
this originated from most amateur teams
starts off with a small project in
visual novels smaller projects can be
around a few hours of play time so with
the collective team experience of
exactly zero when it comes to writing
drawing or producing any visual novel
content they all agreed on a decision
that I imagined when something along the
lines of this alright chaps now I know
none of us have any experience making
visual novels and we're a complete group
of independent strangers with no
concrete hierarchy with our team but uh
Audi chaps feel about making a full
length multiple pass 30 hour plus visual
novel on our first
attempts
what can possibly go wrong
everything everything you could possibly
imagine went wrong at the end of 2007
the team initially thought the game
would be finished in around 2009 little
did they know that they would be signing
up for roughly five years of development
hell the plan was to make a full visual
novel right from the get-go and with the
collective inexperience they had they
blindly charged forward haphazardly
assembling texts and pictures to be
assembled in order to create the first
playable version of the game many of the
side characters were created early on
and the main cast started getting more
personality which became the basis for
the final game and eventually the first
Alpha version of the game is done which
is codenamed grid one this was actually
leaked onto 4chan reigniting the
interest in the project allowing them to
add Nicola Mafi as the game's composer
and Delta who would help customize the
game's engine and UI but it soon became
clear that this project was the ultimate
chekhov's gun as even with a smaller
team there were still so many ideas
floating around with no one really
knowing where they should go sometimes
it felt like everyone was working on a
different game leading into this weird
frankenstein-like project of different
parts and half the fun was just trying
to see where everything could go they
soon realized that all the work they'd
done would lead to disastrous results
further down the line unless everything
was scrapped and the writing work starts
all over again dejected the team tried
to salvage what they can and craft the
basic structure of the whole game act 1
the first chapter of the game would be
shared between all paths and written in
collaboration between all the writers
until it splits off on the last day so
they all decide to rewrite act 1
together and then everyone moves on to
their individual story paths that makes
sense right sounds like a way better
approach and things seem to be going way
more smooth wrong later on or realize
that things could be better and
restructured the whole things by
themselves this would Mark the beginning
of the third rewrite for act one soon
the project would lose its character
artists and the main writer for Lily
stories so new members needed to be
found this would be the first instance
of many of the staff coming and going on
the project a new writer to was found to
handle Lily's story but throughout the
next few months the dev team went
through a bunch of artists who would
join but then quit soon after for their
own reasons after eight months the
project didn't even have a single
background image finished and there was
a clearly massive issue of a complete
lack of character artists as well
despite this through sheer Blind Faith
that a visual novel without any
visuals was a problem that was probably
going to be fixed down the line the team
pressed on writers finished their drafts
for their story paths the engine started
looking something not too far removed
from the final product a group of
editors was brought in and in Spring of
2008 their faith was rewarded as a
ragtag group of artists came aboard to
work on the character and CG art for the
game however one massive aspect of every
visual novel is of course the background
art and unfortunately they still had
zero background artists background art
takes a ridiculous amount of work to
produce and a very specialized skill set
so to fix this the team went back to
their roots and asked the community for
help for the various settings of the
visual novel the team would ask people
to submit photos which would be put
through a filter to change the aesthetic
to be a bit more anime-esque a user
named Jovi would contribute a great deal
but coincidentally Oro and crud actually
visited Japan and were conveniently
using some of the pictures for the
game's backgrounds as you can imagine
most of the images were taken in places
across Japan but the high school where
everything was set in was 10 taken in
the very Japanese High School of Brown's
University in Rhode Island unfortunately
the rotating doors of workers coming and
going wouldn't stop according to Cameron
working on the project very much felt
like it could drop on a day-to-day basis
remember during the entire duration of
the project not a single person was
getting paid and there was nothing
keeping people on this project other
than their own drive to want to finish
it after producing some music Nicole
quits out of boredom while the original
background artist and director are fired
from four leaf Studios but enough of all
that bad news because finally for some
good news near the end of 2008 the
entire script for the game was finally
done and after reviewing it all it was
decreed but it sucks it still read like
a weird stitched together mess of
earlier ideas but this is fine no
problem minor inconvenience because on
the bright side and I say bright with an
overcast Pooh Brown covered filtered
kind of bright VR production was way
behind schedule anyway so they had time
to rewrite everything in ads 1 from
scratch
again learning from their mistakes and
better experiences the team was able to
produce a much better final script that
ended up being the actual one used for
the game plus blue 123m came on board
and started composing some additional
background music for the game as well
it's interesting because while acts 1
technically had a two year long
development cycle everything in the
final product was actually done in a
little over half a year only the
original coding stayed consistent from
the beginning and some earlier developed
music was carried over about two years
after the first posting on 4chan writes
rewrites re-re-rewrites members joining
and leaving and the project teaching on
death the entire time at one was finally
finished and released to the public in
April 2009.
acts 1 was only meant to be a litmus
test and while some of the devs
originally thought that would only be
shared or talked about on message boards
that inspired this madness it ended up
generating a significant amount of
attention online that Blues everyone's
expectations away and gave the team a
dub they thoroughly deserved and at this
point probably needed there were even
people online willing to come on board
to translate the game to dozens of
different languages Japanese Hungarian
Russian German and since then even way
more languages by various different
groups more significantly they managed
to add a substantial element in their
game in the form of animated openings as
an animator Mike Canal offered his
services to the group which they
accepted it took weeks for the devs just
to go through all the feedback so they
could probably account for what worked
and what they could approve on but it
became clear that they were on the right
track with all that attention came a
rise in ambition the team had learned
leveled up and knew they could do better
and so they made the hard decision to go
back and rework significant parts of the
script from various angles as you can
imagine reworking and scrapping huge
parts of the game script was not an easy
thing to do but at this point it wasn't
something they weren't already used to
in early 2010 another artist was asked
to join because unfortunately the team
soon realized that they didn't actually
have enough people to produce a large
amount of art they would need for the
final game in fact you could argue that
the whole team was severely on demand to
deal with the sheer amount of work that
needed to be done however adding any
more people to organize and manage might
have made things detrimental in a kind
of different way so they decided to
carry on steadily with the people they
had even though production was still
played with communication issues between
all of the Departments and they were
still so much artwork that needed to be
finished despite all of the supports the
team was starting to get weary but they
didn't stop pretty much everyone on the
core team had burnout at one point and
had to take an extended break from the
project but miraculously everyone stayed
on board after constant setbacks for the
first time in a while they could
actually see the ending in sight from
Summer 2010 onwards it was not no longer
a matter of if this game was ever going
to come out but just a matter of when
with rejuvenated motivation a strong
sense of hope and a better idea of what
the [ __ ] they were actually doing they
knuckled down and cracked on and after
their years of turmoil a revolving door
of writers composers artists and other
staff members through its entire
development on January 4th 2012 exactly
five years after the initial 4chan post
was released to the public
[Music]
they did it they actually did it this
ragtag team of amateur developers not
only saw a full length 30-plus hour
visual novel to completion but somehow
it was actually really good the team
were met with almost unanimous praise
from fans and critics alike moved many
many people while also reaching a far
larger audience than they ever intended
or imagined mainstream gaming Outlets
talked about it it got people who never
play a single visual novel before try it
out it reached far beyond the little
anime and visual novel boards on 4chan
that it started on even writer the
original artist that helped start all of
this wrote a post on a Japanese blog
thanking the developers expressing
heartfelt gratitude for their combined
efforts to this day katawa Shojo remains
a cult classic to beloved by many
personally I first heard about it like
many other people seeing people talk
about this a rogo from 4chan revolving
around dating disabled girls and of
course hearing that my curiosity was
peaked as my gut reaction was oh God
let's see how big of a train wreck this
is gonna be and yes while there were
some arrogate scenes in it like so many
other visual novels initially marketed
as a rogue is that people realize were
actually so much more than that katoa
Shojo was exactly that what I was met
with was not only a wholesome but
inspiring story about a group of people
who strive to push past misfortunes and
hardships that life had given them this
isn't just the type of story that people
enjoy this was the type of story that
could really change people's lives teach
them something about themselves and the
relationships with people around them
and to me seeing a story so powerful so
impactful knowing the journey it took to
get there is nothing short of a miracle
because I think the most impressive
thing was the reaction from 4chan itself
4chan the board of hardened degenerates
the community with some of the most
unfiltered unflinching jaded people on
the internet had their hearts moved this
was the game that taught 4chan how to
feel it was the game team that broke
4chan itself I downloaded the game for
fat material now I'm so I'm stopping up
looking back on the
back on the jack off to this God damn it
I got a life you know I'm crying about
it you [ __ ] broken me V
guys I'm seriously crying [ __ ] [ __ ]
tears right now like you wouldn't
believe I'm not even at the end yet
fuckfully studious for doing this to me
for making me feel these feels help me I
think you've broke my bonus for [ __ ]
sake I haven't stopped thinking about
this game for two days straight and this
[ __ ] hasn't helping [ __ ] I was prepared
to fap but I wasn't prepared to feel
katawa Shojo is still free to this day
available for download to anyone who
visits the site and if you haven't done
so already I highly highly recommend you
give it a shot even if visual novels
aren't usually your thing I wanted to
make this video not just to fill in the
gaps of the story for those who were
curious but also to highlight this game
to those who might not even be aware of
his existence at a time where visual
novels are probably more popular now
than they've ever been katua Shojo
continues to be possibly one of the most
influential and downright inspirational
stories that I feel not enough people
talk about these days because as great
as the story of the game is I think the
story that came to pass for this game to
be made is just as impressive many of
the devs have gone on to work on more
official industry projects like
serialized books the artists have gone
on to work on many other official Vision
novel projects my Canal has made quite a
name for himself as an animator and
Cameron O'Neill even now is in the
process of working on a visual novel as
we speak which also shows that despite
their Collective inexperience there was
real talent in this team and as
improbable as it was for this many
talented strangers to be able to
congregate and persevere for this one
project it would be the last time this
is the first and only project Four Leaf
Studio have publicly stated that they'll
ever make and while there's a chance
certain members will work together in
future projects the collaboration of
this core team of talented people has to
this day remained a one-off and that's
why to me katama Shojo stands as a
unique anomaly of its time we may never
see again I've seen school projects
crumble for Less this was a project made
by a team with no experience no budget
no guarantee their work would ever be
seen fueled by pure passion but it
wasn't just passion that got this
project made this game was teaching on a
knife's edge for most of its development
from conception to completion so many
unlikely things needed to come together
so many serendipitous events needed to
happen so many stars needed to align for
this thing to not only come to fruition
but be as incredible as it was and that
is the miracle story of katawa Shojo
foreign
[Music]